obst das war knapp in nur 44 tausend
kilometern entfernung also nur etwas
weiter entfernt als stationären
satelliten mit 36.000 kilometern flug
der ab 2012 c c4 an der erde vorbei zum
ersten mal wird jetzt aber ein solcher
vorbeiflug genutzt um vorbereitungen für
den schutz der menschheit vor
einschlägen solche asteroiden auf der
erde vorzubereiten
jetzt den klicks um science-fiction von
der frankfurter buchmesse herzlich
willkommen
den atom 2012 c c4 kennen wir schon seit
fünf jahren also 2012 wurde entdeckt
aber in dieser zeit konnten wir ihnen
nur sieben tage lang beobachten
das soll jetzt anders werden denn ein
einschlag eines asteroiden wie 2012 den
c4 hätte verheerend sein können ein
anschlag direkt in einer großstadt hätte
wirklich furchtbare folgen haben können
bis zur vollständigen zerstörung wie bei
einer atombombe der vorbeiflug soll
jetzt genutzt werden um die asteroiden
erkennung und nachverfolgung zu testen
denn das ist die voraussetzung um in
zukunft asteroiden aufzuspüren und dann
zu zerstören oder eben ihre flugbahn zu
ändern zum ersten mal kommt dafür die
neue behörde planetary die fans
koordination zum einsatz diese hatten
usa letztes jahr eingerichtet um erdnahe
asteroiden zu entdecken und zu verfolgen
sie gelten als auslöser von
massensterben auf der erde alle paar
millionen jahre steuert ein großer
asteroid auf die erde zu der das leben
tatsächlich bedroht die nasa hat
deswegen das ziel bis 2020 alle erdnahen
asteroiden die größer als 140 meter sind
zu entdecken denn genau diese könnten
der erde gefährlich werden und zwar zu
einem millionen sterben für einen
experten plädieren deshalb nun mal
wieder für eine bessere weltweite
zusammenarbeit und den aufbau eines
koordinierten frühwarnsystems wirklich
effektive abwehrstrategien sind aber
noch nicht ausgezählt
2012 tcp wurde ja eben erst 2012
entdeckt damals konnte er aufgrund
seines verlaufs allerdings nur wenige
tage beobachtet werden seine größe
ähnelt und welches thema szenen der im
februar 2013 über russland explodiert
war
die explosion von chelyabinsk hatte
damals lediglich eine druckwelle
ausgelöst sie beschädigte mehrere
tausend gebäude und verletzte rund 100
menschen einen einschlag hätte dagegen
die stadt komplett zerstört verglichen
mit der hiroshima bombe hatte dieser
asteroid die 20 bis 40 fache sprengkraft
entsprechend tnt waren es 600 kilo das
soeben sind ein überbleibsel von der
entstehung unseres sonnensystems die
meisten von ihnen ziehen
glücklicherweise weit entfernt von der
erde um die sonne zwischen den planeten
mars und jupiter und doch die erde ist
ständig bedroht von kollisionen mit
erdgas zu jeden viele objekte sind klein
und verglühen in der atmosphäre ohne
dass wir es merken dass ein
himmelskörper in die atmosphäre eintritt
und explodiert oder einschlägt kommt
allerdings öfter vor als wir denken
wie oft das in den letzten 13 jahren
passiert ist das wurde ja erst jüngst
bekannt wir haben ja darüber berichtet
26 studenten sind auf der erde
eingeschlagen bauch bekommen sind
findige wissenschaftler sie hatten die
idee beim weltweiten atomteststopp
überwachungs netzwerk nachzufragen ob es
andere größere explosionen auf der erde
gab und es waren 26 in 13 jahren
lediglich ein einschlag wurde dabei
vorher gesehen alle anderen kamen im
wahrsten sinne des wortes aus heiterem
himmel
jedes jahr schlagen also zwei größere
asteroiden hier auf der erde ein und
bisher hatten wir großes glück denn die
gesteinsbrocken schlugen mehr in wüsten
oder in sonstigen unbewohnt
und nein oder verdampften bereits in der
atmosphären die jetzt begonnene bahn
verteuerung ist also ein erster mega
wichtiger schritt um die menschheit vor
einer katastrophe zu schützen eine
wahnsinnig wichtige zivilisations
leistung ohne die wir als menschheit auf
dauer nicht überleben könnten wenn er
kein video zum thema und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den genau auf die glocke hier geht
es weiter mit athen bedrohen die erde
jederzeit mit noch mehr infos zu den
gefahren die von asse hinausgehen
spannendes video klar also nicht
verpassen kauf klicken und ansonsten
bislang lag